-Mike Birbiglia,
welcome back to the show.
-I never thought
I'd have to say this.
-How am I going
to follow Cher?
I mean, how on earth
are you going to follow Cher?
-You're following Cher.
What a great show.
-What are you doing?
-Cher and Mike Birbiglia.
-I mean, come on.
-She's unbelievable.
Dude, congratulations,
by the way.
-Thank you.
-It's out. It's officially out.
It's on Netflix.
-"The Old Man and the Pool."
-"The old man and the Pool."
I watched you build this,
by the way.
-Yeah.
-I just want to say how
impressed I am,
how talented you are.
-Thank you, Oh, my gosh.
-What a great writer you are.
-I mean, seriously, this was --
how many years was it?
-Four years in the making.
-Yeah.
-And you go, Jimmy,
I'm working on this thing.
Hopefully I'm going to turn it
into a one-man show.
And then, hopefully,
and then I'll go on Broadway,
and I go,
"What do you mean?"
-Right.
-Yeah, that's just the plan.
I'm doing this.
And hopefully
I'll go on Broadway.
I go, "Good luck."
It's like saying, like,
I'm going to go build a house.
Yeah.
-I watched you build a house.
Build a house, yeah.
-You built, and you're like --
And I went to go to the theater
in East Hampton.
-Yeah.
-I went to -- I went
to a bunch of different gigs.
-Yeah.
-And watched you
change the act,
take jokes out,
add jokes in.
-And we worked it out
on the podcast...
On your podcast.
-Jokes, and --
And then now I'm trying
to convince you
to do stand-up again.
I've been trying
to Jimmy to do stand-up.
We went out --
So, okay.
The closest I got you recently,
,he Comedy Cellar, which is
my home club in New York,
is we went -- you and I
went to Carbone Restaurant,
which is near the Comedy Cellar.
-That's right.
-And it's funny because
I've been -- we've been friends
for a long time,
but I didn't realize, you know,
how people, they come
at you a lot like --
It's...
No, it's wild.
You're like --
you're like a friendly
Irish Sinatra.
You know what I mean?
People are just like --
No, I swear,
we're at a restaurant.
And literally
it's like a -- it's --
People are like Jimmy Fallon
over here!
You know what I mean?
Like, literally.
Like, people
would just be like "Mr. Fallon."
Mr. Fallon,
come right this way."
They're like,
"We got a table for you."
And they're like kicking
the people out of the table.
They're like,
"Get out of here!"
-They don't do that at all.
-No, that's what it was.
And they were
just like "Mr. Fallon,"
we picked these grapes from the
1922 from an Italian village.
We got them just for you.
We saved them for you."
And I'm just like --
I like --
I'm an Italian,
you know what I mean?
Like, I should get
this treatment.
I'm Mike Birbiglia.
I'm an Italian celebrity
no one has heard of.
And -- But yeah, man,
they go crazy for you.
-That was unbelievable.
We did get some grapes.
We got --
-They went crazy.
-They brought --
It was like everything off...
There was no menu.
It was just like, bring it,
"Mr. Fallon, we got --
Here's some risotto.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And then there's, literally,
it was just like, we got
Chinese food from Canal Street.
We're like -- we didn't want --
We don't want Chinese food.
Like, why?
-What are we doing here?
What is happening?
At one point --
At one point they're just --
One point the guy just --
And I'm not making this up.
He goes, we got oranges
and walnuts, you know?
And I'm like, "Oranges
and walnuts."
-We had fresh clementines
and walnuts.
-And then like --
I was like, I don't even know
what this meal is anymore.
And then the people next to us
is like a couple,
there's a couple.
And they were just like,
"Well, we eat here all the time.
We never seen
the clementines and walnuts."
-That's right.
-And then Jimmy,
and Questlove,
can speak to this,
you just start
giving them the food.
You're like, here,
you can -- you can.
You turned the restaurant
into "The Tonight Show."
You're like hosting --
you're hosting the restaurant.
-Giving the food to everyone,
yeah.
-It's like the kitchen to you,
you to the people.
-But then -- but then we went
to the Comedy Cellar.
-Yeah, so...
So what happened
was I said -- I was like,
let's go to the Comedy Cellar.
You're like, I don't know.
I'm like, you just look at it.
Just -- just come watch.
It's fun.
It's my favorite place to be.
And you're like, sure.
So we go, and then
Chris Rock shows up
and it's like dream --
dream person to show up.
Like, one of my favorite
comics of all time.
-Comedy legend, yeah.
Comedy god. I love Chris Rock.
-And so you're
like -- you're like,
this is the greatest.
And then we're --
we're in the back.
This is a small room.
It's 150 people, and you're --
and you look at me
and you go, "Should I go up?"
In my mind, I'm just like,
"No." you know what I mean?
No, no, not because you're not
great or you shouldn't,
but I'm just like,
Chris Rock is on stage.
Like, this seems like maybe,
you know?
But then I'm like, absolutely,
Mr. Fallon,
you know what I mean?
Like, I became --
I became the Carbone people.
You know, Mr. Fallon,
Mr. Fallon. And then...
-Chris is doing his act.
-And then
Chris invites you up
to tell stories.
And it was like --
Can I ask you to tell the story
that you told
about Bon Appetit magazine?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is about you.
I'm here to tell you about you.
-So the Bon Appetit magazine
is in my new special,
"The Old Man and The Pool."
Can you tell that story or you
don't want to tell that story?
-I can tell.
I mean, it's a long story.
We'll have to probably
cut it out of the show.
I don't know, but I was just
telling this story that...
-I love this story. If they
cut it out, they cut it out.
-My mom was a very,
very funny person
and always she would call me up
and she would say something
to either annoy me
or something like that.
And I go, "Alright, mom,
I can't take it anymore.
I got to hang up."
She's like, "Don't hang up.
Wait, wait, one more thing,"
you know, whatever.
So I called her once.
I said, hey mom, I go,
Bon Appetit magazine called.
They want --
for Mother's Day
they're doing a special issue
and they want to know
if you have any recipes.
She goes, "Oh, my God,
Bon Appetit magazine?
Oh, my. I'm going to be
in Bon Appetit magazine.
Oh, my God, I don't know
what I'm going to do.
Maybe my shrimp recipe."
I go whatever.
I go think about it,
call me tomorrow
and let me know.
And she said okay.
So I get the phone call
the next day and she goes,
"I found out, I got the recipe
that I'm going to give.
It's my cheesecake recipe."
I go, "Okay, great, I love it.
Well, can you send it over?"
She's like, "Yeah,
daddy's going to type it
because he knows how to use
the computer or whatever."
So my dad, "Uh, I'll type
the thing."
So he types out the thing,
makes a big deal.
-That's a really friendly
impersonation of your dad.
[ Laughter ]
-He loves it. He loves it.
-[ Roars ]
Cruel. Cruel.
So he emails it to me,
and so I get the thing.
And so I give it to Bon Appetit
magazine, emailed to them.
They go, alright, Jimmy,
thank you.
Thank your mom so much.
You know, we have to --
we have to make this recipe
to make sure it's good.
Yeah, sure.
Of course.
So I go do whatever
you guys gotta do.
So they called back
the next day and they go,
we made your mom's recipe
and it's fantastic.
It's really good.
I go, "Okay, cool, I love it."
She goes, "Can you ask her,
is there a story behind it?
You know, did she get it
from grandma or somebody?
Is there something
behind this thing?"
I go, absolutely.
So I call my mom, she goes --
I go, "Bon Appetit
loves you."
"Oh, my, God, I'm going
to be Bon Appetit."
I go, "They want to know
is there a story behind it.
Is it grandma's? "Like, what's
the what's the story.
She goes, "Hold on a second."
And she puts the phone
on the chair,
and I can hear her
scuffling over to the thing,
and I hear she opens up
the counter, the cupboard,
and then she goes.
I hear paper, like.
And she goes, "Yeah, I got it
from a Bon Appetit magazine."
[ Laughter ]
-Great story.
-I'm hanging up. I'm hanging up.
I'm hanging up the phone.
I've had enough.
-Okay. So, okay.
You told that story.
It killed.
The next day it's in page six
that you showed up
and did stand-up.
And can we bring up
the thing?
Because this is a this
is like "Entertainment Tonight"
Said Jimmy Fallon surprised
Chris Rock and Mike Birbiglia
with a stand-up set
at the Comedy Cellar
in New York City.
I want to point out
who isn't bolded or underlined.
[ Laughter ]
So, Jimmy, how do you get bolded
and underlined?
Because I'm just hoping
that after my new special,
"The Old Man and The Pool,"
I get bolded and underline.
-That's all you need.
-I'm sick of it.
You know?
-He wants to get bolded
and underlined?
That article was written
by the staff of Carbone.
[ Laughter ]
-Mr. Birbiglia.
Mr. Birbiglia.
-I don't think we're going to
have time for the other story
because we're --
-Okay.
-But do you want
to tell it anyway?
-I mean, I'll tell it anyway.
You'll have it.
Maybe you put it on --
maybe you put it on YouTube
or something.
-I'll put it on YouTube.
-Okay.
-Well, I'll tell you what
because I want
to talk about this.
Because I know you love
all The Roots, we know that.
-Yeah.
-But you went to an Uno party,
a celebrity Uno party.
And who throws it but
Questlove.
-Questlove, yeah.
-And I know he did the
pre-show music for your show.
And so you go to the Uno party.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Why are so many celebs
playing Uno?
-"There are some celebrities
on the planet,
and also Mike Birbiglia."
That is a real public --
It's an actual publication.
It's an actual...
There it is, there it is.
There's the tuba.
There's the tuba we've been
yearning for in comedy.
-Oh, my gosh.
-My God.
-That is unbelievable.
"Some of the biggest celebrities
on the planet,
and also Mike Birbiglia.
-Okay, so Questlove
throws these parties.
I get made fun of for going even
though I am invited.
-Yes.
-You're My first invite.
-That's nice. Thanks.
-First.
-The first invite.
-Thank you.
-Yeah, we love you.
-Alright, well...
So he had one that was clue
themed for Halloween.
And so I dressed up
as Colonel Mustard Stains.
And so Colonel Mustard,
except my daughter, Oona,
my wife Jenny,
poured mustard all over
my cardigan sweater.
-That's pretty smart.
-And the problem --
the problem with dressing up
as Colonel Mustard stains
is that it's the only person
whose costume has a smell.
So I'm just the guy at the party
who smells like mustard.
Like at first they're like,
oh, that's cute, Colonel Mustard
stains.
And then you smell like mustard.
And I was a little drunk,
so I was the guy who was drunk
and smells like mustard
at Questlove's party.
And I don't usually
get drunk, but --
but we were playing Jenga,
and I kept losing at Jenga.
And the penalty for losing
is you have to take a shot.
And so I had like four shots,
and so I was the guy --
My wife is like, Jenny was like
I've never seen you this drunk.
Like, I was just the person
who was just like,
"Does anyone want to play
Jenga?!" You know what I mean?
Like, I was that guy who also
smelled like mustard.
And -- and so --
So you know how when,
like, when you're drinking,
you end up saying things
you're embarrassed about
and having really
strong opinions.
So I had really strong opinions
about people
who were at the party,
because there's a lot
of famous people there.
So like, for example,
like maybe I'd be talking
if I were drunk about
like the movie "The Wrestler."
But like Darren Aronofsky,
who directed "The Wrestler,"
was at the party.
So I went over to him
and I was like,
"Hey, why does the wrestler
have to die
at the end of "The Wrestler?"
[ Laughter ]
And that didn't go well,
because --
I know.
I was just -- it was terrible.
-I've never even seen you drunk.
-No, I know.
-But you're dressed as this guy.
-And I'm dressed as that guy,
and I'm like...
-Yelling at Darren Aronofsky.
-...why does the wrestler
have to die
at the end of "The Wrestler?"
And then he was like, you know,
he had a really good answer.
He's like -- he's like,
you know, he died
so that we as the viewer
don't have to die.
We can experience it.
I was like, oh,
that's what "The Old Man
and The Pool" is about.
And I told him about "The Old
Man and The Pool."
Yeah, yeah.
"Old Man and the Pool," yeah.
-But yeah.
So anyway, here's my sentimental
Thanksgiving thing.
I'll say -- it's like it's
things are hard right now.
It's like a hard time.
People are having a hard time.
This special, it's about being
alive and it's about mortality,
and it's about bonding
with people you love.
And I recommend it to people
who are age 12 to 112.
Like, I'm really proud of it.
I hope people like it.
-It's great for
the whole family.
It really is great.
And congratulations.
Dude, no one works harder.
No one. I can't believe
I watched you make this.
I'm so honored
to be your friend.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Mike Birbiglia
in "The Old Man and The Pool."
Take a look.
-We would recommend
you move out immediately
until this is resolved.
So we move into an Airbnb,
which, by the way, no breakfast.
Which is one of the letters.
[ Laughter ]
This is a wildly
misleading acronym.
It's like if you showed up
to an AA meeting
and they were like, we're live
streaming and you're like.
I had heard it was sort of
a private thing,
and they're like,
pop open a wine cooler.
We're going to dish some goss.
-Dish some goss.
-We're gonna dish some goss.
Get the family to watch it.
Mike Birbiglia, everybody.
"The Old Man and The Pool"
is streaming
now on Netflix.